Saturday for world power is in fact
Russia Turkey France and Germany are
meeting in an attempt to get a lasting
political settlement back on the agenda
well from all now what lies ahead for
the country we're joined by Ilya ata
he's a member of the Orthodox community
in Syria he lives in Damascus he's a
very good man to talk to
with regards to the feeling in the
situation in Syria right now um Ilya
welcome thank you just let us know then
what is the humanitarian situation as
far as you can make out in Syria at the
moment in which of the worst affected
areas well I think the problem with the
humanitarian is now that things are
looking more like settled in military
except for two region majorly people are
coming back to their home a lot of the
region are destroyed so people are not
seeing anymore where they could live the
international rebuilding of Syria that
everybody was expecting that would show
up the European and American are
refusing to move anything out of it
without having a political settlement
the return of the refugees from abroad
which is something is gonna take time in
the meanwhile they're still cities where
people cannot go back to their home
because they need some financial support
to rebuilt it so as far things are
better in security wise I mean in
Damascus we used to have some times
where we would worried about having some
bombing from the area in Douma hasta but
now nothing like this but people are not
seeing enough where is we're heading in
the reconstruction because no one is
really worried about it as if the big
people were worried about how to finish
or to get the war to the end now that
the war didn't end up the way they were
expecting people are not giving any much
help to human tear in aid even now we
can feel it that we don't receive him
Terry in it I used to have during the
war can you then give us an idea of the
sort of conditions people are living in
because you say that people are
returning to their homes you can
understand if a home has been completely
destroyed but also we see
is where it's a street isn't it and
there are still shells of buildings of
people going back into those buildings
are going
trying to rebuild to repair the house
they have to live in but even that the
infrastructure is not there so the
government is doing their best to
rebuild the infrastructure for the
street like for example we don't have
anymore power problem for electricity
water things are slowly but the problem
with the level of destruction the Syrian
government alone no matter how they want
to do it they cannot go far with their
capacity financial you know after 70
years of war the economic situation of
the government and the country has been
totally vanished so we need more
international help and psychologically I
know it's very hard to generalize but
while the war and we know the war is
continuing but many people hope it will
be over they can see an end in sight and
during that time people were sort of in
survival mode they just wanted to get
through it but now they appear to be
through it yeah are they shocked what's
on the other side yes I think a lot of
people now look like they are lost
because when it was worth was survival
they lived a pure day now they are
looking on the future they are trying to
see that especially psychologically
everyone think that it's over especially
if you forget to region out of Syria all
the rest it look like safe area people
are going back to normal life but this
normal life people cannot really
understand what's out of it where we are
I mean ok the children are going to
school but still some people are they
don't have jobs due to the situation so
people are not really capable of seeing
further down the road in the future
where's where we are going and I suppose
there's a danger to that people are told
oh you can return to your homes now but
they might not actually like what
they're returning to and they might
think we'll our lives could be better
outside of Syria we might leave the
country anyway well the problem is
now the European and I think you just
mentioned about the meeting this weekend
into in Turkey the European are
insisting of the returning of the image
of the people at the refugee in Turkey
Jordan I'm talking about the biggest
number Lebanon but also in Europe the
problem they were a big part of those
people don't want to come back for
different reasons some of them they just
settled if we talk about Europe more
than the region we have a big part of
the Syrian intellectual the Syria the
Syrian with high degrees that those
country wanted them by all means so for
example Germany is is in need for
engineer for doctors
some of them like Canada pulled up some
community they don't want to accept
early and they took those community
because they think they would integrate
better we're talking about minorities
Australia's doing the same thing so the
return of the Syrian refugee is not as
simple as we expect like tomorrow
everything is settled they want to come
back and this is one of the condition
that the European and I think the
problem that the France the French and
the German won't talk about is majorly
the return of the refugees because
Germany has a very big number France is
not a very big number actually it's a
small number compared to the rest but
that's why that's one thing they won't
talk about the other thing they won't
talk about is their armed people so when
we talk about French
European people who left their country
to come to Syria to fight now part of
them are in need lip but they are gonna
do so the problem is more complicated
than appearing and some people now are
thinking really about leaving Syria even
though after seven years they never
thought about leaving Syria because they
they are thinking about finding a place
where they could survive that's not good
and I think for the Syrian mosaic to be
changed as it was this could be shaking
for the future of Syria well absolutely
I mean when you talk about the future of
Syria if you've got a country that
people don't want to return to and you
feel that your most professional
civilians have been cherry-picked
if that's the right word to use by other
countries in their given asylum I mean
there's potential for further problems
big problems in Syria and more conflict
is there in the future
well the problem is rebuilding Syria as
everyone is talking about rebuilding the
stones if I may use this word rebuilding
buildings it's something you get money
you can do it but rebuilding the social
social between people the relation
between people which was in Syria in the
past and Syria was very proud of that
having out say one of the biggest
diversity and religion in ethnic group
and all those people lived really well
with each other now to rebuild it it's
not anymore
it's not as easy as it was but without
it Syria want to be Syria what it was
other things that give you hope though
yeah I mean everything we've talked
about just over the last few minutes
sounds desperate but other things you've
seen that gives you hope I think what
give hope to people that we Syrian has
Syria during history we go back to the
Syrian history all over the thousands of
years Syria was always the middle point
of fights between superpowers up to the
I would say up to within 1920 we could
say that there was a big fight in the
Middle East in Syria between the British
and the French even like we say you know
it was between the free after Sykes
because they still fought between each
other but Syria was rebuilt Damascus was
destroyed twice by the French in 1925
and 1941 they bombed Damascus completely
but it was rebuilt I think the Syrian
people has a strong feeling of survival
they will rebuilt it they will do it but
the time that the people are brought
they should leave us alone and I think
till now some people don't believe that
they should do that
sure just lastly we have got this
meetings I can advise at the weekend for
major countries talking about potential
rebuilding Syria do you have what are
your expectations well I think each one
is looking for his part of the cake
which means his problem France Germany
have their own
which is the the Salafist who are
originally especially France they have a
big number of people who went to fight
in Syria and now they are afraid that if
they go back to France what's gonna
happen we are talking about 60 to 80
thousand fighters still in need Lib if
they go back if you know if we talk
about 500 out of them France will be in
trouble they cannot handle this problem
Germany about immigrant Turk is about
also how they should keep their
influence in Syria but I think the
Russian are still trying to talk about
the unity of Syria where they don't
accept
it's like Syrian which the Syrian
government won't accept not a single
student would accept that Syria will be
take a part of Syria will be taken apart
what part of the Kurds are doing all aid
labs so serious will be United but I
think they are meeting just because each
one has a problem we are not talking
about a global problem each one will be
talking about his own problem and that
what the meeting will be about and just
lastly I think we've got just a minute
to take left
with regards to the politics within
Syria itself is that a situation that
can be resolved after this horrendous
civil war well I think the syrian will
decide by themselves we're talking about
like European we don't want this
president we don't want these people we
have to do it so Syrian will find a
solution and to be a pure Syrian
solution but for the moment nobody is
giving the possibility for the Syrians
of their own problem and it should be
all the Syrian solution between Syrians
you